hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about a fatty liver and your thyroid
okay if you have a fatty liver chances
are that's going to slow your thyroid
down because let's take from the top
high levels of insulin from a lot of
refined carbohydrates and frequent
eating will put fat on the liver
you're going to get inflammation and
you're gonna get scar tissue which will
eventually develop into something called
cirrhosis in fact this is called
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease okay
this can also come from being an
alcoholic so the damage from high
insulin from a lot of sugar is almost
identical from the damage from alcohol
especially if you're consuming it from
high fructose corn syrup okay because
the fructose really will damage the
liver or faster than other sugars and
the average American consumes forty four
point seven gallons of liquid sugar
every single year okay so how do you
know if you have a fatty liver well if
you have a gut you're gonna have a fatty
liver okay because the fat is spilling
over from the liver around the abdomen
it's called the visceral fat however the
best way to identify a fatty liver is
ultrasound but what's going to happen if
you have a fatty liver the function of
the liver is gonna go down and the
cholesterol is going to start building
up too because you're going to get a
decrease of production of bile so when
you have a liver damage and not enough
bile
you can't effectively remove cholesterol
too well okay so that's one problem and
then we have the thyroid over here the
thyroid produces a hormone called t4 and
then the liver helps you convert t4 to
t3 which is the active form of a fire at
hormone this is inactive this is active
if the liver is damaged
you're not going to convert enough into
t3 and you're going to have a condition
known as hypothyroidism so now you have
a slow thyroid which will then build up
more cholesterol slow your metabolism
cause more weight gain so really high
insulin will affect your thyroid
because of the liver all right so what
do you do well what you do is you get on
keto and another fascinating to handle
this okay
increase a lot of cruciferous vegetables
increase vegetables in general to help
heal the fatty liver over time you can
reverse this if it's not too far gone
the next thing I would recommend is
choline you can get it in a powdered
form some people are mixing it with the
electrolyte powder to make it taste
better but choline is the B vitamin to
help remove the fat off the liver pretty
fast I mean you can do it within within
months so I would add that in there with
really healthy cruciferous vegetables
and doing a version of keto I call
healthy ketosis and of course in a
minute fasting that's how you're going
to handle the fatty liver that's how you
can improve your thyroid all right
thanks for watching
hey guys so I'm doing a survey of a
future video and I wanted to find out
what your biggest body problem is so
that way the content is aligning with
something that you are personally
interested in so please click the link
down below fill it out and I will create
the video thanks